okay good morning everyone and welcome
to the health and wellbeing board on the
21st of january 2022
and we have received apologies from both
the chair and vice chair of the
committee so our first item of business
today is the appointment of a chair
um of the board
for today's meeting
uh do i have any nominations
um for chair of the boards today
i'm happy to share thank you alex
thank you diane uh is that
a nomination seconded
i'm happy to second alex ditzara council
officer of the ccg
thank you sarah
do we have any other nominations
i don't see anyone so therefore i will
vacate the chair and hand over to diane
thank you alex and if we could put the
agenda item up
the gender or for reference for people
to
see
particularly those that are joining
remotely um from cars in various places
across the country i think
and we have a number of apologies today
um including the chair and vice chair so
we'll note those apologies first of all
um please alex
any other apologies that we need to know
today
uh we've received apologies from gareth
james
and we've also received them from uh
councillor heinz councillor holden
mark jarvis uh
and caroline davidson
okay thank you
um so if we uh welcome everybody to this
morning's health and well-being board
really important um items on the agenda
today and an important point for the
health and well-being board as we we
move into
a period of review and reflection on how
we operate for the future which we'll
go into later
and if if everyone's okay we'll move on
to the minutes of the last meeting has
everyone received minutes
no hands or objections to that and can i
confirm that everyone takes them as a
true record
i can't see any hands to raise any
issues so thank you for that are there
any matters arising from the minutes
that we need to take that aren't picked
up in the agenda today alex
not that i'm aware of
them thank you
if we move on then to declarations of
interest are any decorations that people
need to make as we start the meeting
this meeting is being recorded
no thank you very much everybody let's
move on to questions received from the
public have we received any questions
today alex
no questions have been received lovely
thank you alex
if we move on then to and take the cdoc
annual report um and i think this is
this elena uh presenting this
no diane it's me helen oh hello helen hi
hi okay
thank you alex i've just
thanks dan
thanks chad uh alex i've just sent you a
set of slides by email if you could
bring them up on the screen it'd be
really appreciated but um i'll make a
start
thanks alex
so um
just to
um in terms of a well-being message
obviously we'll be talking about um
child deaths for the next 10 minutes so
just to make people aware
of the sensitivity around um this issue
but i'm helen collins i'm acting
director of public health at trafford
but for the last two years i've also
been um
sorry alex it's not that one that's for
the um lga
the other set thanks alex so for the
last um three years i've been chair of a
tameside um trafford and stockport's
cdop panel um
and
it's the really important process seed
up so we meet the panel
meets we receive notifications of all
children that die um across tame side
traffic and stockport there's four
panels across the whole of greater
manchester
um and they are grouped within different
localities so we could just stop port
homestead and trafford
um and we receive notifications into
the panel
of children aged 0 to 17 years who die
um and
we collate the information we have an um
an administrator named shelly birch who
works within the public health team who
collates information from all the
partners and then um the panels then
review the information
and look at what lessons could be
learned or where we could affect policy
or influence change
so obviously child death overview
process is an incredibly um sad process
to be part of but it's a very unique
process as well and it's so important in
um obviously we recognize that every
death of a child is a is a tragedy
but we need to understand as a system
why our children die uh what we could do
to prevent this but also where it is
inevitable and for a number of young
children and families you know the death
of a child
it's a planned process that might be
illness or
a condition that leads to um the child
dying and it's about how we learn to to
give that child and that family uh the
best death they possibly can do and
provide the support that's necessary for
them as well so the cdot panel is
incredibly important in terms of public
health social care and and the wider
system
the things that we learn from
understanding how our children die and
how their families live is really
important and provides such a richness
of information to our policies around uh
children's and families
so the process works um it's it the data
isn't as straightforward as you'd
imagine so we receive a notification
that a child has died and then that'll
literally be the name the address date
of birth and
possible cause at that point of why the
child's died
so that's called a notification when we
have the panel and it may not be within
the same year that the child dies
we review the we review the evidence and
then we close the information so just to
give you an idea when we go through the
slides that um
we'll be talking about notifications and
closed cases as well so this slide here
um you can see
how over time um the proportion of
deaths
across the different localities
so um
over the two years um for because we've
what we've done due to the pandemic we
would usually do an annual report to the
health and wellbeing board but we've um
eleanor has supported the writing of
this report and we have a as um
2019-20 2020-21
and across those two years we were
informed across the three boroughs of 79
children who had died
for trafford for those two years it's 19
children that died so 24 of um the
panel's volume was for trafford children
and for the last seven years so we're
looking back now to try to get more
understanding of
the causes and the patterns underneath
why our children die and for the last
seven years we've had 99 child deaths in
trafford
so alex if you could move on thank you
so in terms of the notifications if we
look at the ages of our children that
die you can see there that
the majority of the the children were
notified of are aged under one years
and there's a number of reasons uh
key reasons that we look at um under
with that death of under one years and
that's often um issues around
prematurity um and pregnancy maternal
health
the children as they get older um the
causes of death obviously obviously
change some may be due to life-limiting
conditions that they're born with some
maybe due to accidents sadly we do have
a very small number of young people who
complete suicide
um and so it's quite quite a mixed
picture as they get older
but the under ones very much there's
some strong themes that come through
from our under ones
thanks alex
and understanding how proportional
proportionate death is for our children
and young people in terms of
characteristics um you can see here in
terms of the ethnic um breakdown of our
notifications that it's predominantly
our white uh white british population in
terms of
how how it looks across the panel but i
think it's really important to note that
25
of our deaths are in non-white groups
but um it's proportionate to our
population so about 20 of our population
belong to non-white groups so you can
see there it is comparative but i think
it's again incredibly important to know
which is again identified in the report
is that there is a number of um
you can see unknowns there and
potentially that could sway and skew the
information so if those unknowns for
example were all incorrectly coded and
those children belong to non-white
groups then we would have um a different
picture there in terms of
proportionality and that's a really
important note which comes through all
our recommendations is just around the
quality of the data that is recorded by
a number of different partners but that
is something as a cdot panel and a cdot
system across greater manchester we're
working to improve
thanks alex
so you can see here that um
the spread across the quintiles the
deprivation quintiles and it's a really
interesting one we have to be incredibly
mindful obviously because numbers are
small but you can see here that um we're
looking at potentially twice as many
deaths in our most deprived 20
of our population compared to our least
deprived
it's hard to conclude obviously because
you can see the real kind of mixed
picture within the um groups in between
but but it is important to note that we
do have that um inequality there in
terms of our childhood deaths
thanks alex
and then we're moving on to closed
panels so these are the cases that um
the panel has reviewed over time um
within the in within the time frame
there so um within 2019 20 and 2021
um
and the way we do the panels is that
it's an what we were classed as an
expert panel so there'd be a designated
nurse there's two designated um
pediatric consultants on the panel we
have police social care
um
we have the ccnt team public health
and a number of other partners will join
when there is a specific um
case that needs to be reviewed so for
example cams will join if there's a
mental health issue
so you can see there that um
67 cases were closed within this time
period
it's a smaller number due to the impact
of the pandemic so obviously the panels
met initially face to face
and a number of our
panel members were redeployed into
different roles during the pandemic so
that led to a delay in us hearing the
cases and being able to discuss the
cases um but we are now we've gone to a
virtual panel that meets monthly at the
moment and and is working incredibly
well because it just allows everybody to
join um and so over this time frame
we've managed to review and close 15 of
trafford's cases
and you can see the causes there
of death within the closed cases so
again um
obviously this isn't representative
because it's that small sample that's
been that we've been able to review but
you can see perinatal neonatal events is
is you know a factor in both years we
have children who are born with life
limiting conditions or genetic
conditions
infections so that may be
where a child may have died from sepsis
or pneumonia
sudden and unexplained deaths which are
always incredibly tragic and these are
children who are often found by parents
um
in their cuts or beds the following
morning and then we have some others so
they may be our young people who
complete suicide or die from
misadventure or um die as a result of an
accidental death as well thanks alex
so just wanted to pick out some key
points here from the reports i'm sorry
for the banging in the background but
there's roofers next door which is
driving me slightly crazy i have to
admit but um the deaths under ones so
the themes were talked about within the
deaths and ones um
are prematurity so we do see a number of
our children born under 28 weeks and
they're less likely to thrive and
survive
children who are born with a very low
birth weight and also children who are
born um
you know multiple births so twins or
triplets
have a high risk of dying within the
first year and you can see obviously
these factors are not interdependent of
each other
but we need to really think about here
as a system um how we work with um
maternity how we improve um the health
and well-being of
mothers and but also it's about that
kind of live well that smoking cessation
healthy weight so that when women um
become pregnant then they are you know
as healthy as we would um hope them to
be before they go into the nine months
of pregnancy
in terms of unexpected and expected
deaths so um we talked about
understanding and being able to support
families and you know where there is an
expected death but we do see a number of
children who die from unexpected deaths
so an unexpected death is a death that
occurs um
within 24 hours of of not having contact
with medical or not being expected to
die within that 24 hours so you can see
there that two-fifths of our deaths
are expected across stockport thames
head and trafford stop what has the
highest proportion of um
expected deaths um and um
stockport at times that has the lowest
so you can see that actually only 28
of tame-sized children are expected to
die so um
that's a piece of work that thomes i'd
have taken away to look at to understand
what that actually means and um
what that looks like for their
demographic but that's a piece of work
that we're also looking at a greater
manchester footprint as well thanks alex
so modifiable factors this is a really
important kind of
issue for our health and wellbeing board
so this is where
factors are identified that could have
influenced the outcome for that child
so there may be a number of different
things who so um
we look at things like
alcohol use smoking
weight
domestic abuse and other social factors
as well and you can see here you know
it's it's quite significant although the
numbers are small for the in terms of
the children who die um you can see the
impact that the modifiable factors have
and for public health and prevention
these are really crucial to to our work
going forward so alex if you can move on
to the next slide it describes in a bit
more detail
so you can see here um the modifiable
risk factors were identified
in 55 of our closed cases in 2019 20 and
48 in 2020 21 and looking through here i
think um all services can reflect on
these um modifiable factors
and and determine kind of action around
them so smoking is a significant
modifiable factor we um
you know in terms of prematurity and low
birth weight um parental smoking is key
um but also in terms of infection and
long-term outcomes as well
substance misuse where parents
may be misusing substances both
during pregnancy but during um the life
of the child as well
co-sleeping
and we work really hard and our health
visitors are excellent in terms of
conveying messages around co-sleeping
but we still do see the tragic events
where parents grandparents carers have
fallen asleep with a baby and suddenly
um when the adult wakes the baby has
died
uh domestic abuse is a key factor which
i know is very close to dianne's
portfolio and leads that for our council
we're doing a huge amount of work around
domestic abuse uh healthy weight so um
issues around healthy weight so where
you have a mum a first-time mom for
example who may not be a healthy weight
then the likelihood is that that weight
will increase as she goes into a second
pregnancy
and there are really complicated issues
such as um
the quality of the scan for example um
and the ability to determine any
underlying health issues in the baby
before birth um if the scan is difficult
to do so maternal weight is is you know
really important for us uh mental health
um and that's incredibly a high profile
particularly coming out of the pandemic
not coming out of the pandemic but as a
result of the pandemic neglect and not
mis not attending appointments ivf so
where there is particularly issues
around multiple kind of um
fetuses being implanted we often see
poor outcomes um for the babies who are
born and then other factors so um you'll
see these are really important kind of
factors to cdop so
um the often the impact of a review will
be that we write national bodies
to inform them of um
an issue or an incident that's happened
so
we now have uh lots of regulations
around safety cords on blinds for
example and that's come through uh from
the cdot processes also button batteries
button batteries now have coatings on
them initially they didn't and sadly led
to a number of children dying um after
swallowing the button batteries and so
other factors which are modifiable often
feature in our childhood deaths or being
a young carer
overheating gang culture
um and and other issues such as that
thanks alex
so moving on to the recommendations
there's eight recommendations and these
will go to each of the health and
wellbeing boards the stockport
haynesside and trafford so the initial
group really is around the data and this
is very much for the all cdot partners
so um we will be taking these back and
conveying them to them but for health
and wellbeing boards if you look at
particularly um recommendation for
you know we really need to think about
um smoking across our population so for
public health um there's a number of
programs of work around smoking and
e-cigarettes it's in terms of supporting
our populations to
either reduce the smoking and stop
completely but it's incredibly important
that we support our pregnant women to um
stop smoking
so uh
one of our recommendations to the health
and wellbeing board is to support the
continuation of work through the public
health directorate and
linking into maternity services around
the baby clear programme which supports
pregnant women
but also working in general a population
level to remove to reduce our smoking
prevalence in trafford as well
alex onto the next slide please
um and then the uh three other
recommendations we would um
request are um
around mental health and resilience so
we are
we are um we do have a suicide
prevention partnership in trafford um
and our representative from public
health is uh jilla burgess allen but
it's about looking at um
the relationship between self-harm and
suicide which is incredibly important
and then we also have um
strengthening the links with suicide as
well understanding um young people and
parents and the support that they need
around drug and alcohol use so again
public health we commission our early
break service and that is something that
we will be working with um our service
and commissions to understand um links
into to mental health and then also um
the impact of domestic abuse on mental
health well-being and resilience
um we are recommending to health
well-being board to continue this to
support the reduction in co-sleeping and
promote safe sleeping so we have uh the
health visiting review on the agenda for
later on but obviously it's incredibly
important that we
support the messaging out and not just
to mum what we have seen is um instance
of co-sleeping with dad or with other
family members grandparents for example
so we're looking across greater
manchester of how we can convey messages
not just to mum but to the wider family
of the importance of um baby having a
safe sleeping space
um and that that's really crucial and
then looking at um
how to improve the outcomes of babies
that's the final recommendation to the
health and well-being board is to
improve the outcomes of babies um by
looking at a number of different areas
so that's obviously looking at the drug
and alcohol
relationship um
looking at how to access high quality
antenatal care early in their
pregnancies
um the issue around ivf which we've
identified
and also working with our maternity
services in terms of um evidence-based
healthy weight interventions as well
so
just wanted to share this cdop report
with you there's a huge amount of
information in here
i've tried to pick out the key the key
bits that i thought were important um
and
hoping that the health and wellbeing
board will um accept and agree the
recommendations so that we
in public health then can look at an
action plan a system-wide action plan to
improve the outcomes for our children
thanks
lovely thank you helen and they're
really detailed and
difficult to hear but a really important
report isn't it so are there any uh
thoughts and questions that for helen
first of all before we move on to the
recommendations being accepted jill oh
i'm glad you've
joined in time jill for that
thank you
sorry i'm late colleagues i had a
national call and but it's finished so
that that's really helpful and just in
terms of thinking about the
recommendations and the findings just
making sure that that there is that
connectivity across to
other forums and places where there can
be some traction in terms of that
detailed action planning
so
um you know just in terms of thinking of
children and young people's mental
health that is something that came out
from the schools conference in terms of
our young people's biggest priority
so clearly we need to think about that
how we get the synergies there the
safeguarding um partnership was looking
at that
but there are some aspects that might
sit within the safe closing partnership
but i think it is a health and
well-being issue so just in terms of
that connectivity across co-sleeping
being another one you know and when we
get into the detail of the
recommendations just having that line of
sight and that sense check on
who needs to drive this forward but um
some really clear recommendations which
are very helpful thank you
thanks jill and it's really important
isn't it i've got a list here of a
number of groups i think this needs to
be
seen but that might be part of the
action plan i think let's bring eleanor
and i'll come back to helen
hi yes and really good report and it's
always very hard to to read
just on the multiple births at ivf and i
think this is one that we really do need
to be doing some um campaigning work or
publicity work for with families because
understandably um when when people are
going through ivf they they can often
think that if they have two babies
implanted at once that that doubles
their chance of having a healthy live
baby at the end of it but actually it
reduces the chance of of um a successful
outcome because twin births are and
triplet births are are inherently more
dangerous so i think it's something both
um for conversations with the providers
of ivf services to make sure that they
really only implant two two or more
fetuses um in very very exceptional
circumstances that that absolutely
shouldn't be the norm but also a piece
of work with our with our general public
just having that really quite
counter-intuitive conversation about why
multiple birth
is more dangerous and why why we
wouldn't encourage it um in
particularly in ivf where where where it
is you know obviously it's
in the main preventable unless um
unless that's identical twins
yeah thanks lot i think that's a key
point in the numbers in the ivf list
there were very high weren't they um
with 23 noted so i do think that is a
key issue to have a look at this next
thanks elena for that any other
questions i can't see any other hands up
and so i think
onto the recommendations then are there
any objections to accepting the
recommendations in full
i can't see any objections so i think
they are all accepted i think the the
point helen um i suppose is where does
this feed into now and there are
numerous places that need to be aware of
the uh the findings and think about
overlap with the suicide board the
mental health board the children's
commissioning group the
children's scrutiny so and as part of
the planning now in the implementation
will that be taken account of where this
needs to feed through so that work
can be tracked back for the health and
wellbeing board oversight
uh absolutely so we'll review and i'll
um speak with jill around um a view on
where this should go in terms of
children's governance but i think start
well the children's commissioning board
and if scrutiny would welcome the report
i think that would give it additional
traction
as well so
um if i speak with jill and confirm
yeah that would be helpful and and i
think uh also speaking to jane slater
because i think live well and possibly
even age well because if you sleep you
know sleeping in the same bed as a
grandparent we do need to make sure
that all of the groups and all ages are
considering the risks
that would be really helpful thank you
so thank you do you want to come back in
it was just to say i think startwell is
the place in terms of governance for
children as well as
the the safeguarding partnership because
the commissioning group will feed in to
start well and i think we'd have
all of the key people at that that forum
but yes we can pick it up offline helen
lovely thank you george
i apologize i just think it might be
useful to take it to the ccg board as
well and to get that sort of spread
across the
you know the health system at that level
yes um i'll ask sarah to pick that up
because i know there's a there's a lot
of um changes over for the ccgs for the
most appropriate place for that to flow
in through
through there or wherever that may be it
may be one system board latest hours you
want to come in
hi diane um
surely we can pick it up um
a ccg board but in terms of with wider
partners it might be worth looking at
how we take it to one system board so
i'll take that as an action as well
lovely thank you sorry that's great
thank you helen for a really
comprehensive report
really important area um and i think the
the key for the health and well-being
board is how the learning from these
things feeds into prevention in the
future and that is
fundamental for us all and particularly
picking up on helen's points about the
um the work that public health and team
are driving around reducing smoking
and
healthier weights etc and we'll all feed
into that as well so thank you for the
report and most welcome
let's move on then to the next item
which is i think the public health
annual report
yes and it's um it's me presenting this
diane thanks um alex have you got the
slides
so everybody should have seen the annual
had a copy of the annual report um it
was included in the papers and the
slides are just um screenshots and so on
from from the report
so i'm just going to
quickly run through some of the um
things that we've uh identified that
we're wanting to bring to people's
attention i think before i do obviously
there's a list of recommendations at the
end of the report some of them will
overlap with some of the recommendations
from that cdop report and also we always
get an annual report from the um health
protection forum so i wonder whether as
well there might be a purpose for this
group to think about not only who picks
up some of the recommendations but
actually how we group some of these
recommendations together so that we can
see where we've got overlapping
recommendations and that we're able to
follow those up and make sure that
the different organizations are only
asked the same question once rather than
six times so that was just a thought for
thinking about how we plan our responses
later so if you go on to the next slide
alex
so
i think um this year's annual report we
really focused on inequality um we're i
think it's a public health team we're
we're really pleased that the council
institute has chosen reducing health
inequalities as one is its three core
areas
last year our annual report was very
specifically around the inequalities
um
and the exacerbation of inequality
through covert this one is following
that up we've also picked up some of the
themes as well from the 2019 report
about
carbon reduction and um obviously again
that is one of the key
themes for for the council and key teams
for the prior council
so in
trafford our health ex life healthy life
expectancy gap which um people who have
been on this world for a while will will
know that this is the
area that we're particularly interested
in because we have quite wide inequality
between our richest and poorest areas on
this measure and this is a measure where
if you have a long life expectancy but
really poor health life healthy life
expectancy that means that your your
older years are spent in less good
health than they could be that's not
good for you it's not good for your
families it's not good for society so it
really is important that we try and
increase keep our healthy life our life
expectancy up as high as we can but that
we really keep an eye on our healthy
life expectancy and the diseases that
are associated cancers and
cardiovascular disease
contribute to an enormous amount of that
healthy life expectancy gap and that
inequality between our richest and
poorest neighborhoods and those diseases
associated with factors such as smoking
alcohol use physical inactivity obesity
and poor mental health so those are
these continue to be the areas that we
want to focus on in trying to change our
indicators in trafford and make sure
that we get better outcomes on those
because we know these are the the big
wins for us in terms of improving that
healthy life expectancy
um and so on the next slide
i just wanted to draw your attention to
really the dramatic impact of coveting
our children's mental health and the the
demand on services that have been
occasioned through this so our
children's mental health has really
suffered during this time we're seeing a
big increase in demand for our children
and young people's mental health
services and including that within that
are eating disorder surfaces
um
i think you know children's mental
health is and particularly well at any
point in childhood poor mental health is
so difficult it's difficult for the
child it's difficult for schools it's
difficult for families and we really are
struggling to meet the demands but when
you see this level of increase
and these are the people who know their
way around the system well enough to get
into the system and
capture that demand so again it's
something that i think and i know jill
will completely agree with me on this
this is an area where we really need to
be working out how can we do as much as
we possibly possibly can to support
these children who are experiencing poor
mental health but also what are the
things that we can do
often through schools health visiting
school nursing services that reduce the
demand for services and make our schools
in particular places that are healthier
places for children and as and our
children do as well as they possibly can
and supporters as well as they can be
um our next slide
is just really um as i was writing this
report i became increasingly interested
in
trust and how trust plays out and the
impact of a lack of trust on
service use and service access it was
particularly broad brought to my
attention really around the vaccination
where we see this big
change with this big difference between
people from more deprived areas and
people from more affluent areas in their
willingness to be vaccinated so people
in the most affluent areas are much more
willing to be vaccinated have much less
hesitancy than people in more deprived
areas
um there was a lot of there's been a lot
of talk through the pandemic about the
role of ethnicity and different people
from different ethnic groups having
different um chance
except willingness to be vaccinated
higher rates of hesitancy particularly
in our black british
and black populations however when you
take out the impact of deprivation that
ethnicity ethnicity difference drops it
is removed so this is this is a we're
often picking up a function of
deprivation which we may in which we may
sometimes attribute to other causes
when i was thinking about this and about
trust i thought about
our voting rates
and we know that people in more deprived
areas are less likely to vote that has
all sorts of consequences for them
um including potentially that their
people who are less likely to vote may
end up having their views less well
represented however much hard people try
because people are more
understandably and this happens this
isn't a political point at all but
people listen more to people who make
more noise so i just thought i'd do it
we'd do a um correlation to see if there
was any relationship between where we
you know to look at that relationship
between deprivation and voting and
deprivation of vaccination and we saw
this you know really very very close
correlation but on both factors so it
really starts thinking about if if trust
and deprivation if deprivation is
damaging trust
that if we can tackle deprivation and
increase trust we should be able to
increase both the number of people who
participate in the election processes
and and in our democracy and that's so
important in a representative democracy
that people are well represented
and the second part is that
we don't only see this
deprivation deficit around
uh vaccination for covid we see it in
all other vaccinations and we see it in
um screening uptake as well
so i just thought i'd draw people's
attention to that because it feels like
an interesting area for for discussion
and and possibly some learning um so the
next slide
is um
the other thing that we looked at in
this is how multiple factors affect
people and so we know that factors such
as race sex or gender and poverty
contribute to inequalities quite a lot
of that within the report
and the fact they contribute on their
own but of course for many people those
factors aren't the only
factor that they have many people have
many of those factors and we call this
intersectionality
and what we find from this is that
commun
those negative experience so people may
have more negative experiences
and those cumulative negative experience
can lead people not to seek health care
services so we know for example that our
death rates in um this is national death
rates in black women in childbirth and
pregnancy are much higher four times
higher than in the white population and
often it's because
things that those women draw to services
attention are not taken seriously and
that it there is definitely a deficit in
the way that people are treated in those
services there's work going on obviously
nationally and locally to try and
address that and to improve that but you
can see how if you have negative
experiences for example in your
pregnancy when when you really do need
those services so much and you
absolutely have to trust your service
providers that can really
um color your experiences and your
attitude
to later services
um and then the other fights thing we
find with this is that that lack of
trust means that the people who have
most benefit from health care services
are often the least likely to do so
so we we see that inequality exactly
becoming exaggerated we know that the
people who are in living in our most
deprived areas are more likely to be not
vaccinated but we also know that they
have other conditions that mean that
they are particularly for covered
particularly likely to be vulnerable so
they may be living in overcrowded or
poor quality accommodation they may be
more likely to be exposed because
they're doing face-to-face work they may
be living in poverty so their housing
and their food and diet may not be as
good so all of those risk factors
contribute together to make the people
that we would most want to get
vaccinated
the least likely to take up that vaccine
so within this we we think that we need
to be focusing on on the wider
determinants of health and untackling
inequality racism and other forms of
discrimination and really trying to win
back trust we need to do this by
listening and responding to people's
experiences and helping people to
support us to to lead the surface design
and really be part of that and to work
with communities not only to build that
trust but to respond to their needs and
by so doing set up a virtuous circle
and so then the next slide
so within this this report we decided to
look particularly at weight management
and diabetes prevention as there are
interesting examples of where we see a
big inequality gradient so for example
with children um children for more from
more deprived groups are much more
likely to be overweight um in reception
and in year six than later than um more
affluent groups
and diabetes prevention is an area where
we know that if we can stop people
getting diabetes we reduce this risk of
heart disease and other cardiovascular
disease we improve their quality of life
you know it's it's a it's a huge thing
to try and get our diabetes rates down
we know that we have a population who is
um you know we across the country we
have high rates of obesity
um and we really do need to tackle that
but we need to tackle that in a way that
doesn't increase stigma around
overweight and obesity because probably
one of the worst things you can do is
try and make people feel bad about their
weight we know that people with poor
mental health issues or issues right you
know
health diet and
weight are immensely psychologically
driven they're immensely difficult um
difficult things to tackle and people
and the stigma particularly for people
who are severely obese is really
dreadful the way that people are often
treated
we need to be making sure that we you
include planning in our um in our work
with them to improve our health policies
particularly around takeaways
and particularly access to takeaways
at the end of the school day and we need
to be able to try and increase the
outlets that provide affordable healthy
food
across the whole of the borough
we need to be
working with our schools to make sure
that they all deliver
school meals that either meet or exceed
the school food standards the school
food standards aren't particularly high
but i don't think all of our schools are
meeting those standards at the moment
and it's really important that children
get a very good diet when they're at
school
obviously i'm going to be talking about
getting people more physically active we
still have about a course of the
population completely inactive and we
need the easiest way to do this or one
of the very easy ways of doing this is
build physical activity into people's
everyday lives so through active travel
we need to be looking at our air quality
and our carbon emissions and trans
travel and transport a massive part of
that
um so again starting young and getting
the school streets um offer we've got
funding um from transport for greater
manchester five school streets this year
so we really hope that we can work
develop that and expand that offer and
make sure that those ones the ones that
we've got the funding for a success
we're looking obviously in detail about
our commission services for weight loss
and trade making sure that they are
acceptable and appropriate for our
different communities
massive piece of work we need to do with
the vcse organizations and i know people
on this call will be very interested in
doing that and then there's the work
obviously with the hospitals around the
waiting well for people who are waiting
for operations particularly important at
the moment as so many people are waiting
with that back plug
and then our more general
recommendations
we are really looking at how we use the
corporate plan and how we tied the
recommendations we're making here into
the recommendations and the measurements
that are in the corporate plan so that
we have a single place of making sure
that everything is measured and reported
on rather than trying to make everybody
do lots of work to different
organizations to different targets so it
really is about how do we make sure that
these targets fit as well as possibly as
they possibly can do within the
corporate plan but critical to that is
doing that reduction in inequalities
between our most and least deprived
groups and subgroups so it really is
about not only looking at our health
outcomes as a whole but also that
reduction in health inequality within
them
um and then i mean we've put other
recommendations in which
the poverty one obviously ties into the
poverty strand of the corporate plan and
the climate change one into the carbon
reduction lines
and then the final slide
is um really about this this
co-production that we've been talking
about for a long time in the development
of trust and how we manage to do that
effectively and how we measure what
we're doing and how our communities feed
back to us on that and how we hear those
voices so i think that's that's
everything sorry it's taken a little
while but i hope that's been helpful
thank you ellen that really helpful
summary of a very very detailed and
helpful report
and what we're really clear about is the
report is not just coming for us to nod
at it is coming for us to influence work
as we move into our new world around
their integration work at ics
and our wider changes that each of each
of us are facing as organizations
and so i'll start with any questions or
comments before we move on to consider
the recommendations so dorothy
i'd just like to say i i really do
welcome and the report particularly from
the health inequalities perspective it's
nice to see that the wider determinants
of health
and deprivation are actually being
linked so we have a real understanding
of what the driving
issues are around some of our poorest um
residents particularly in trafford and
certainly from a vse perspective we are
doing an awful lot of work
around these areas to support some of
these recommendations so it's very very
much welcome that um particularly the
data
is there to
influence some of this change
thank you dorothy and a really well made
point isn't it we we've got to see the
issues of our different outcomes for
people living in different boroughs in
traffic addressed and i know helen and
ellen that are committed to helping and
supporting each of us because it's not
their responsibility to achieve that
it's ours as a collective partnership
and and so i'll come back um later on
how we measure success i think and and
you know changes in those figures as we
implement work so thank you dorothy i
think george and then jill
yeah
i suppose it's just
i think it's a really useful report uh i
think it's really good report i think
the timing
is particularly good because we are
going through the system change and we
are focusing in within that system
change much more
engagement
at a local level and working with
communities and neighborhoods so i think
that's our opportunity i think we've
also got an opportunity to learn the
lessons from covert and how some of the
work that's been done
again by the system but led by public
health and the community engagement team
of talking to people about covered
hesitancy about you know
really engaging with people we've got
some real lessons that we can learn to
take forward you know into the new
system and as dorothy highlights working
with so vcfse group so i think it's a
really welcome report i think the
timing's
ideal and i think there's really a lot
of opportunities for us for the future
so thank you elena
thank you george and again some really
helpful points and kogi has exposed the
inequalities even further hasn't it but
this has been an issue for a long time
and i think we're all key
partners in this group we want to make a
difference and start to see some of that
in reality
jill
thanks diane and colleagues elena thank
you for the report and and the
contributions just a couple of quick
observations for me if if we're really
wanting to think about the wider
determinants of health and landmark in a
prevention space
i think we need to think about things
like child development and speech and
language and i was surprised that that
didn't feature in the report because we
know that covid for example is hugely
impacted on on that for our children
and that does lead me to that whole
thing about neglect and
i didn't really get a flavor of that in
the report because i think you point
about if we have healthy well children
the likelihood of them becoming healthy
well adults is is just tremendously well
made
and my final comment slightly tongue in
cheek helena would be if you can tell me
how we can ensure schools including
academies do anything i would really
welcome the benefit of that and i the
reason why i'm saying it is slightly
tongue-in-cheek i am not disputing the
need for the recommendation to make sure
schools offer all of our children a
healthy well-balanced diet it's the bit
about making it happen and so again and
i know diane will really want us to
think about that how we make these
things a reality um i think it is the
devil in the detail rather than the the
statement of intent
but some really interesting things
highlighted and genuinely support the
focus on prevention and my final point
would be
it's not just about children's mental
health it's about adult mental health as
well because children live in families
and in communities and yeah you're
absolutely right and far more expert
than i am eleanor on um
the impact
of the pandemic on our children's
emotional well-being but it's also
impacted on our adults
and again if we don't
ensure that they're well the the impact
on our children will continue to be felt
but thank you for the report
thank you jill again really helpful
points and i think um heather and i and
sarah have often discussed the
need for all age mental health support
to be considered as a collective not
just two separate pieces so i think we
would absolutely support that piece
okay i i don't think i just sorry just
to come back on a couple of the points
and thanks very much for the the points
that were made um
absolutely jill i think one of the
difficulties writing the public health
report is that there is always
so much stuff we want to include
and that we can't include because we
would then have a report that was you
know 900 pages long and nobody would be
able to read absolutely take the point
about speech and language absolutely
take the point about adult mental health
and mental health is listed obviously at
the start of as one of the main issues
what we tried to do in this report was
was shine the light particularly around
diabetes weight management and um
inequalities and then and then these
issues around trust and co-production
but um i i absolutely take your point
and um helen when she talks about the
school nursing and um health visiting
review i'm sure we'll also be picking up
some of the points around making sure
people get that access to speech and
language services therapy services as
soon as they can in terms of how we
implement this that is i mean obviously
it is the challenge we we all want
things to be different and we all know
that it's we're not in a place where we
could you know we can wave a wand and
insist people do things it is about how
do we both work with our schools for
example in the example you gave but or
but with any of our other providers to
try and encourage them to do the work
but i think the other point the other
thing is that it is about perhaps some
of those conversations with the public
to tr really try and bring our
population with us and make people and
support people to understand some of the
impacts of a poor diet at school etc
and particularly for our children where
that may be the main meal of the day
really making sure that we can we can
work with people so that we create more
of a demand for a healthier society as
well as supporting people on trying to
deliver that and these these offers
people will often say oh this is going
to be more expensive well a not
necessarily and b when you count in the
cost of doing things badly it quite
quickly starts to be very expensive not
to do this right
so i think it is how we how do we
engage with this i think the school
nurses have a massive role in working
with the schools to be honest in how
they support the head teachers and
others to change some of these things
and that that's something that i'd
really like to see
as as um school nursing gets back on its
feet after the pandemic i'd really like
us to see those school nurses being able
to work much more effectively to make
schools into healthy school settings
thanks helen and
leading us very nicely into the next
item but if i can just conclude this one
and so this is an independent report of
the director of public health
and so the recommendations and the
findings are what they are
as a group of health wellbeing partners
um can i just ask if people are um happy
to accept the recommendations and start
to work together with public health to
look at how we now implement this across
our system
it's a bit like it's a wedding when you
ask whether anybody has any objections
isn't it jill
and i totally accept what you say it's
an independent report and it's eleanor's
responsibility as dph and it's her
report
helen's responsibility is to act interim
dps
um i just i do query the word ensure in
terms of schools absolutely comfortable
with we have to exert leadership
absolutely comfortable with we have to
influence and try and make it happen but
if we're saying we ensure
we might be setting ourselves as a
system up to fail so that would just be
an observation really i don't want to
water it down in terms of the traction
but so
agree the ambition of addressing these
issues let's say um perhaps is a word um
that will be acceptable to helen and
elena
um but as a partner in this i think all
of us want
want those ambitions to be achieved i
think that's the key and we all have
areas that we will need to influence so
care homes for instance for myself
i can't tell them what to do their
individual private bodies but i can try
to influence is similar isn't it ellen
did you want to come in quickly and then
i'm going to move us on to yeah
so my suggestion was when it comes back
to the conversation on the
recommendations for the cdoc report my
suggestion is that um helen and i work
together to put together some an action
plan from this that we run past the key
organizations that we think are liable
that we would want to deliver it that
will give the everybody an opportunity
to change the wording into more
realistic wording as as as they feel we
can then bring that back to the health
and well-being board and it may be again
that it would be something that we would
want we would definitely want obviously
the one system board and the ccg to be
involved in um but then what we need to
do perhaps is um think about how
um you know that a bit like when you do
a safeguarding report you know you get
you get the recommendations and
sometimes you get a bit of pushback
about you know they will get watered
down and then they may get strengthened
again so it's just to make sure that we
have that process so i think the report
is obviously the report of helen and
myself um
but the action plan should be owned by
the health and wellbeing board and
therefore the action plan needs to be an
action plan that everybody here can sign
up to and
own the delivery the targets and we will
be what we will be doing is putting um
trying to work up with smart targets so
that this becomes an action plan that we
can um we can own and deliver through
this group great thank you elena and we
have a lot of work already in play that
these recommendations feed into an
influence
and maybe make them more specific which
will be helpful and then there may be
some gaps where nobody is already or no
board is already
carrying out tasks and those would be
the particular ones that we would want
to make sure picked up is everyone happy
that we proceed now to implementation
plan
yes lots of nods uh elena you've still
got the handle is that now i'm turned
back thank you thank you to eleanor and
helen um for a really detailed uh report
which is again challenges us and that's
what this is about it's making sure that
we're always aiming for the next
improvement that we can make for our
residents
one question i have um for
both of you is the measurement
arrangements and as to how we know that
we've succeeded i suppose and we've got
a whole suite of measures that we've put
in place as part of the um integrated uh
health and social care work
that we are using to track uh change the
implementation of changes and the
impacts that they have so can we make
sure that we align
each of the um areas to those measures
so that we can then start to see where
the dial starts to move and i think a
question for
uh
ourselves as a health and well-being
board is what is our ambition in each of
the areas what are we trying to achieve
in that shift and as we move so that'd
be helpful if you could pick up that as
well and thank you and lots of messages
in the chat eleanor and helen that are
very
positive feedback for you both
so thank you very much for that that
item
as i said that led us very nicely into
the next item which is the um feedback
on the review of the health visitors and
school nursing um teams and services and
which i think could be really supportive
in taking these outings forward um helen
is this yourself
pleading
it is thanks chair and like you said it
fits really nicely into the agenda
doesn't it with cdop and the far report
as well um so
the report is attached and i'm not going
to go through it for bait i'm just going
to pick up some of the key um aspects of
it but members of the board are asked to
note the findings of the review and our
next steps
um i think
we need to start by acknowledging the
importance of the health of their health
visiting
and the school nursing services so for
health visitors for example um it is
the one um service that can go into a
person's home when they have a baby um
it's a universal offer it's incredibly
important
and that's that's
one of the driving forces behind the
review for school nursing um it's
incredibly important um service that
supports our young people and our
children provides you know crucial
services in vaccination weighing and
measuring but as our children grow and
develop as well our school nursing
service in trafford uh provides drop-in
sessions around mental health sexual
health uh substance issues and all the
other um health and wellbeing challenges
that young people experience so um i
just wanted to make note of that to the
board of how important our school
nursing and health visiting um services
are
and and the important role that they
play in our systems
so um this this paper has been um
shared with the one system board and
also with the tlco executive board and
we're welcomed by both
um the review has been a stop start
review we started i think i'm trying to
remember eleanor but i think it was back
in 2018 and then there was a pause and
then the pandemic and a further pause
but um donna uh sega a public health
consultant in our team along with amy
gibson and um
lucy what has been working incredibly
closely with um
the colleagues from mft and we've forged
a really strong relationship and
partnership in terms of this review and
going forward and it's a model i think
that we would like to replicate with
other pieces of work that we do
so the review um looked at a number of
different elements of both the school
nursing and the health visiting
service so we have to remember that the
health system services mandated public
health service and school nursing
is obviously one that's incredibly
important to our population
so public health commission um school
nursing and health visiting and our
provider is mft
and our contract um
is due to a change in april 2022
so this um service specification that
we're writing in response to the review
is is likely to be um
a stepped approach where we will start
with a strong core offer which we
already have but just articulating that
again in a service spec and one that
will develop over time in terms of step
changes as well so the objectives of the
review were to evaluate our services
against national and
wider evidence to look at the cost
effectiveness to review and appraise the
model in terms of meeting the needs of
our children and families
to propose options for future delivery
to develop a reporting framework and to
strengthen the governance around that as
well
so we set up a health visiting um
review board which i know richard who's
on the on the meeting has been part of
along with dan his colleague and nicola
marsden as well and so really good
engagement from all partners
um we did an evidence review and a needs
assessment and have done some
consultation as well out with
professionals staff and service users
all of this has been um
taken into account in the review and
some of the key findings um there's four
key findings really one around the
performance of the service so it you
know the evidence suggests really good
performance across health listing and
school nursing but we are ever kind of
um challenged by the lack of an
electronic patient record for our health
sitting in school nursing service
staffing has been a challenge in in
terms of recruitment and retention and
that was that's a national issue but
it's particularly played out in trafford
and that was a challenge before the
pandemic but during the pandemic and
post pandemic as well that continues to
be a challenge but it is improving now
service delivery so um it's kind of
looking at the ongoing development so
obviously
the service in particular the health
fitting
service has got national guidance of
what it has to deliver but we're all
aware that families the way we live as a
society and the way that families live
is ever-changing particularly with the
emergence of things like social media
and
digitalization as well so it's trying to
understand the service delivery element
of it and then we had some other uh
findings so that was a cut i think the
key finding um was the
the pressure and the increased demanding
that safeguarding has on our health
sitting in school nursing service but
also recognizing the important role that
they play and then other issues as well
so um how we feed into um
supporting young offenders and the early
help and uh trafford team together for
example so they were the findings in
terms of the outcomes uh what we have is
a number of outcomes that we're working
to and will be included in the service
specification that donna is currently
writing so um
the electronic patient record every
single meeting i'm sure richard will
agree every single meeting we have
around health system school nursing is
about the
absolute need for the electronic patient
record in terms of both um reporting but
also
being able to extract performance and
understand um
activity across the area so um there are
plans in place in terms of a business
case has gone into the epr
into mft so that started to move now
which is really good we've developed in
partnership so um our analysts and um
are
our luci who's a specialist registrar on
public health have pulled together an
outcome framework which went to
um nicola martin and colleagues and has
been agreed so really good piece of
partnership working there and um we're
starting to see some of the outcomes
that we have requested coming through so
that gives us a really stronger
understanding of our services
recruitment retention so like i said
this is a national issue but it's
playing out very much across trafford um
but we are looking at some really good
kind of practices so things around grow
your own health visitors and school
nurses you know um kind of embracing
that enthusiasm that a lot of our
nursing staff and and and workers have
for working with our young people and
helping them to to get the required
qualifications so there's lots of work
going on with nicola and um
colleagues in mft around that we're
looking at um improving the
administrative function as well so
supporting
our health system school nurses um in
terms of
getting the paperwork ready um doing the
appointments and everything else so that
we can get that kind of um clinical
effectiveness i'm not saying that
they're not clinically effective at all
but it just means that they have more
time to focus on the clinical
effectiveness rather than doing the
admin so um improving the admin
strengthening the admin function is a
really important um outcome of the
review
there's some issues around
how
finance and budget is managed but that's
more about shifting it across the
different localities and i think um
this will be ever important when we look
at our neighborhood teams that again
richard is is playing into
and then we've got some ongoing
developments as well so we've obviously
been working very closely with mft in
terms of the covid vaccination program
which i'm sure you're all aware has had
a huge impact on the delivery for school
nursing services so um
our colleagues are and donna and amy in
particular are working with mft in terms
of um
how to support that vaccination program
and the wider vaccination program as
well so hpv vaccination is incredibly
important in terms of our young people
and protecting them into adulthood so
it's just ensuring that the service is
able to deliver um the wider vaccination
programs another elements and under a
consideration that will be fed into the
service spec and the kind of the stepped
implementation of the program is around
the development of a specific um
specific immunisation team
restarting the ncmp which is our
national childhood measurement program
so that was paused last year and is
paused until the end of february but
it's incredibly important that we weigh
and measure our reception and year six
children the national clinical lead for
children has said that his greatest
concern um
actually which is quite interesting
above mental health is healthy weight
for children as he's seen a significant
increase in um obesity in in very young
children so by restarting the ncmp
program it gives us the evidence to
understand across our
localities um
the healthy weight of our children and
that's really important in terms of
inequalities so we're working
together with our school nursing team so
we've provided some support from public
health into that to be able to to do the
ncmp
and then the final and but really
important piece that is still ongoing
under development is an enhanced care
team so what we mean by that is um a
team within school nursing that focuses
very much on safeguarding and supporting
the wider team around safeguarding and
managing demands that way so
all of these changes will be being fed
into
the service specification so although
the service specification is incredibly
important because it articulates
everything i would say um
one of the key outcomes from the review
is the strengthened relationship we have
with nicola and her colleagues and how
we're working together in terms of the
delivery of the health visiting service
and the school nursing service as well
and that's telling in terms of the
working and collaborative working
in terms of the covered vaccination
program and restarting the ncmp so i
think we're going from strength to
strength at the moment but i just wanted
um to bring this to the health of my
being board because obviously it's an
incredibly important
two incredibly important services for
the health and wellbeing of our
population and as jill says not just for
our children but our families as well
and that's incredibly important and
school nursing services and health
issues feed in to an absolute plethora
of our services you know it could be
alcohol early help primary care
specialist services so they are
fundamental in terms of improving health
and well-being
so just wanted members of the board to
note the findings of the review and i'm
happy to take any questions thank you
lovely thank you helen and again a
really important part of our delivery
healthy children grow up to be healthy
adults so it is absolutely fundamental
we get this right i think it's really
important for the board to note that the
great work that's gone on between
public health our
lco colleagues where our children's um
health and statistical nurses services
are located and
uh children's services so it is great to
see that co-production and co-design and
i know we've been talking to a lot of
families and survey works being done etc
so we've got some real um
residual voice in there as well jill do
you want to come in the comments
yes thank you diane thank you helen and
um a really thorough piece of work and i
would echo what diane's just said there
and you're absolutely right helen you
can't go into a meeting without somebody
mentioning the performance information
and the development of the electronic
patient records
and the reason why i say that i think
it's really important that we understand
what we mean by a safeguarding because
actually the number of children subject
to a formal child protection plan has
reduced but the number of children that
are in need of help and support has
increased and i know that sounds like
semantics but it is what's the nature of
the support that they need who's best
place to do it so actually understanding
outcomes not just from a health
determinants point of view but in terms
of what does that mean um in terms of
the help and the support and and who's
giving what will the development of our
electronic patient records will really
help with that would be one of one of my
observations
and i guess the other thing just in
terms of some of the innovation and some
of the things that you talked about one
of the things that we have worked really
collaboratively with our tlco colleagues
on
and um as part of this review is the
development of trafford team together
and that isn't about a separate service
it is about the way people work together
which absolutely does link into the um
locality plans and i know the likes of
donna and nicola have worked really hard
to make sure that that
pilot work we haven't called it pilot
work prototyping work
is um considered within the
specification because it is a way of
working rather than a different service
so
um welcome the report coming again it's
another one of those that probably needs
to go to some different places
particularly start well in terms of
seeing what that looks like and for
start well to be cited on that outcomes
framework and because it's diane's point
you know we need to understand how
effectively these things are doing in
order to to drive forward any changes in
the leadership space so thank you
thanks john some really helpful points
then i think the this has been a number
of times and been well socialized but i
do think starkville will need to have to
see this as well really um i'll bring
maureen in next then
thanks diane and yes really really
welcomed the review and really welcomed
the report i think um so glad that we've
actually got to the point i'm sure you
you are helen where where we can put
this in into a domain where we can have
a discussion about it and and i'm going
to echo jill's first point really uh
it refers i think four times in the
report to safeguarding and safeguarding
as a as a a fundamental part of of the
work of the health visitors and school
nurses but also the pressure that
safeguarding brings and
whilst i don't expect us to do that in
the context of this meeting today i
think we probably do need a an offline
conversation about that safeguarding
runs through the work of every
practitioner doesn't it
in traffic irrespective of the domain
that they work in and i think the
safeguarding partnership and the other
partnerships that have been
mentioned today really need to
understand what that pressure is because
um we don't want the pressure to result
in any
loss of focus on safeguarding and i know
that that's not what this report is
saying but for me it's a slight
a slight ripple across the bells in
terms of what is the expectation what do
we mean by safeguarding as jill said are
we all in the same place around the same
guardian pressures and let's take that
away and really think about it so we can
respond to and support the kind of safe
practice that everybody
involved in this partnership and in this
review will want to achieve so i guess
there's a bit of a there's an offer and
just raising that point there let's
let's do a bit more detailed work around
that well thank you really good report
thanks maureen that's really helpful i'm
sure helen um can feed that back into
the working plans with nicola and i do i
do agree safeguarding can mean different
things so if you haven't been vaccinated
and you become ill it is a safeguarding
issue actually and so there are it does
span a massive
range for defining that will be um
i'm sure has already been part of the
group will be part of the ongoing work
as well
heather
i thank you um a few points really and
firstly welcome the report very much
i've seen it um two or three times in in
different arenas so
i think it's good to raise the profile
um
i think that they um from what i've read
um it's a school nursing service that
has the most difficult uh workforce
issues um and i think it's very welcome
that we can try
and improve this workforce
internally
but
are we then able to retain um these
staff and from what i can gather from
previous and things that i've seen we
have some difficulty doing that
and
i suppose um the other thing i'd like to
pick up is about uh nutrition in schools
really and like everywhere else
everybody um has problems with uh
the level of resources that they have
and i wonder whether our um
schools are adequately
um funded to provide good and
and and healthy meals rather than um
storage basically and support the need
for the
patient record and and i have to say i
was quite
flabbergasted really that we've
almost reversed over a number of years
the fact that we used to have uh records
and we used to be able to judge
uh what um staff's performance was and
and and now we can't
and and just an overall plea that i
think i've raised again in in many
issues it's it's about money
um and i know that we all struggle for
money um
but
i think it would have been useful to
benchmark the level of resource we have
for children services in general and
school nursing and health visiting in
particular with other areas at least of
greater manchester just so that we have
an idea about whether in fact we need to
think about um some of the larger issues
about how we can
and flex and transfer monies um between
um
the various services
thanks
thanks heather and there's some really
helpful points there so can i ask um
whether richard or john wants to just
come in about electronic records because
my
understanding is manual records continue
um but it's it's moving to being able to
electronically report is the issue so i
don't know whether rich or john wants to
make a comment or i'll come back to
helen
um around benchmarking as well as the
digital
records question
i think richard might be um more
closer to the issue about the records
than i am clearly across mft you'll
probably be aware we've got a
large epr program currently underway and
it's about how we link a number of
things together but i'll let richard
comment on the specifics of the of the
community bit
thanks john i know richard that nicola
isn't on the call today
and it may be that nicolas should attend
when his children papers on
and i can answer
um
hi can you hear me diane yes we can now
i'm struggling with my connectivity so
i've just switched the camera off um now
i can answer the questions so uh we we
definitely are keeping records there
paper records so all the visits are
recorded and and
and so on
unfortunately still on a on a paper
basis um actually i had a good
discussion with uh and tim griffiths
who's the
um
director of corporate services for us at
the lco
yesterday so we are
through mft as our
trust now putting together a proposal
and program to move to a full electronic
record as part of emis um and i think i
couldn't confirm
exactly the date that that would be
starting but it's his and our top
priority in trafford for both adults and
children services we came over to mft as
some colleagues will know with a very
old version of emis which just recorded
activity so it requires quite
significant investment uh through the
trust to get it into the right format in
terms of um keeping it as a full uh
record a patient record as we would call
it
yeah thanks richard if if we can secure
a timeline at some point that would be
really helpful i think that we can build
that into the work for this review
thank you richard um do you want to come
back in and then i'm gonna ask helen
about the benchmarking question
sorry it was on the benchmarking
question diane and because one of the
benchmarks that might be just as helpful
to us as our greater manchester local
authorities would be our statistical
neighbours and particularly our
statistical neighbors in the children's
space
of which there are a couple in the in
the north west but actually that might
be a more useful comparison both in
terms of volume of demand and spend so
that was my only observation thank you
yeah lovely thanks jill helen do you
want to come on uh back on and explain
whether that's been done as part of the
review
so we did do um last year heather a look
at the finances so it was done at a
greater manchester footprint and the
localities submitted head count and
funding but the difficulty is um is
different areas
use different monies as well so some
areas i think stockport in particular
use some different grant funding that
they have eligibility for as well so
it's just trying to understand
spend
a dedicated public health
funding
in addition to other monies areas used
but we have done that piece of work we
just haven't included it in the paper
because there's some sensitive
information in there
oh have we done work helen on the um
acquired population head of the
workforce to the number of children they
support yeah and case work yeah so yeah
so we have done that piece of work and
yeah so we we do have that particular
ramp for health visitors and caseloads
um
which
again is difficult to interpret because
it's all based on um allocation and um
need across different localities
um
and it would have been better for nicola
to comment on that but we do have that
information so i can share well i can
give an overview of it via email if that
would be helpful that would be helpful
if we could source that i think i've
seen something in papers about
population head versus and versus case
age management i think it's a good
question and from
the caseload information chair went to
the children's commissioning board i
think in the update there um in terms of
what that looks like so i think that i
think as helen and yourself are
articulating there is some benchmarking
and there is some information that's
available in terms of it sorry diane
look there thank you and again the
recommendation is to note the review and
and
the review will then move through the
system working with the lc on public
health for implementation and
any other issues before we move on then
um
about accepting that recommendation
can't see any hands
um we've got two items left and half an
hour and i would like to spend just 10
minutes on the government the local
government association
review of the health and well-being
board and then move on so we've got 20
minutes on the nhs integrated care
updates okay
so and helen are you taking the local
government association out in
i am yeah sorry i hope my voice isn't
lulling you all to sleep this morning
um alex could you share the slides and
it won't take 10 minutes diane it should
take just a few minutes thanks
alex
thank you thanks alex so um just wanted
to explain i've been working with diane
and the local government association um
to um
implement a
a peer support
um process for the for the health and
wellbeing board so for this board in
particular
and i've just put there's some slides
here there's not a huge amount of
information on them but just trying to
articulate the process so alex if you
could go to the first slide that'd be
really helpful
so this just kind of explains and i'll
share these with alex to share out um
the process of the pled support the
local government um association provides
but it's kind of like a critical
friend um
kind of challenging process that they do
and the other advantage of working with
the lga obviously is they've got lots of
knowledge and insight from other areas
as well
so
the purpose really is to
look at our health and well-being board
look at our wider governance determine
what it is and how we want to
um align the health wellbeing board to
the wider governance so particularly the
icb and the one system board
and to ensure that as uh george said
earlier the time is now in terms of
health inequalities wider determinants
and prevention and to really lift that
uh
portfolio through the health wellbeing
board and to to give the health and
well-being board that kind of drive in
terms of
providing that challenge to the wider
system
so alex if you could go to the next
slide please
so the ask really is is four points in
terms of the health and well-being board
and the peer review is to
to assess how we can align it in terms
of place and and governance to review
the membership um and to ensure that we
have the appropriate membership that all
of the partners and the system is
represented and at the most appropriate
level to review the structure of the
health and wellbeing board and to
encourage that um improvement in impact
and greater collaboration across the
partnerships but also um to recognize
how it fits into the wider structure and
we've heard i think from the beginning
of of introducing the lga process it's a
real concern around duplication so it's
how we align the health and well-being
board the wider determinants the
prevention agenda um
against the one system border gender as
well without without giving it that
duplication because none of us have got
time to um to be doing anything twice at
the moment
alex
thank you so again this this slide i'm
not going to talk in detail but it's
just about how we work together and so
far it's been working really well so we
have a dedicated officer at the lga
called matthew cook who's been working
alongside us and a colleague in my team
jane wagstaff as well has been
supporting the process
so um
at the moment the lga um matt at the lga
is drawing up a survey and we are kind
of work together in terms of
assessing the questions and making sure
it's appropriate for trafford what we've
also done as well if you go to the next
slide alex is um
what we've done so this is kind of the
process so we've signed off the proposal
from the lga to trafford we've confirmed
our two peers so the two peers some of
you may know them um we have julie wood
who is known in the north west and has
been a chief executive of an nhs
organization but is really experienced
in terms of understanding the local
authority social care and health systems
i think what we were very conscious of
is not to have a very la local authority
focused peer or a very health focused
peer we needed to have
people with those skills across the
whole system so julie wood and the other
appear is jonathan mcshane who uh works
down in london but is very involved in
ics and health and wellbeing board
developments down in london but it's
also got a strong um
voluntary sector
background as well
so where we are with those now is we've
met them um kind of ex um
described what our need is really in
trafford for the health and well-being
board and we've shared with them a list
of people that we would like uh julie
and jonathan to interview so my
colleague jane will be in touch with a
number of you on the board um to set up
interviews the interviews should take
about an hour and they're led by the
peer and it is about being as open and
transparent like duty of candy you know
really sharing your thoughts and how we
can work with the health and well-being
board
in traffic in part this review
and alongside that as well is a survey
that's going out out to healthy
well-being board members and other
governance and board members as well so
we did we are incredibly mindful that i
think it was last spring we did a survey
out that information and those questions
have been shared with the lga so we're
not replicating that again and we're
taking the learning from the outcomes of
the responses from that questionnaire as
well and feeding that into the
development of the new survey and into
the interviews as well
so the survey will be going out at the
beginning of february the interviews
will be completed hopefully by the by
mid-february and then the consolidation
of all that intelligence
national policy hopefully should be a
bit clearer by that point and we can
then share this in terms of um
at the workshop so there'll be two
workshops at the end of february early
march um just to kind of shape the
the views a bit more and take the
evidence a bit more and that again will
be led by our peers from the local uh
government association as well
so the aim was to have
this the kind of the um review
um
findings available for our health and
wellbeing board in um
april so that's where we're aiming to be
obviously been slightly delayed
something to do with the pandemics kind
of thrown some of the timings up in the
air but we are back on track at the
moment so i'd really welcome if
colleagues when they are approached by
the lga to be interviewed if you could
be as flexible as possible um in terms
of having the interviews and also um to
ensure that you and your colleagues who
receive the survey complete that as well
so if you could go on to the next slide
please alex i think that might be it
actually there you go that's it thank
you um
so that was it really but i think it's a
really important time to
to refresh and review the health and
well-being board
you know we are the pandemic has really
put inequalities into the focus um
nationally and locally
and we have a forum here that could be
really
and is really powerful but we could
really strengthen in terms of aligning
it across the the new governance
of the health and social care
system i don't know if eleanor and diane
wanted to comment as well
well thank you
hello any comments before i move us on
no i think it's i think it's going to be
a really really helpful review and i
think for me it's really about thinking
how this board relates to other the
other people who can really deliver
change with us so whether that's the one
system board the partnership boards
through the corporate plan or or
wherever because it feels um
that we've been in a place where we've
all wanted to see change happen and i
don't think anyone
would ever argue with anyone's
motivation on this board to get that
change happening but i know there's been
frustration
among number of partners about the pace
of change and and how we deliver um
measurable change so this and and the
role of the health and well-being board
within that has you know we've had a
number of discussions haven't we around
this board about how we make ourselves
more more have a greater impact and
deliver the changes we want to see so i
think this is a great opportunity but
that we need do need to understand
how do we take this forward and how do
we really make it work
thank you eleanor and there's a couple
of points in the chat and john
um
look to see how the board works with the
emerging gm system and helen's responses
yes absolutely i mean it's i think it's
a really crucial point this for us in
our our development
one two think about
how the priorities that we set as a
health and wellbeing board are then
filtering through into delivery in the
system
how do we influence and impact the the
emphasis on prevention work
across our
programs how do we strengthen the voice
of this group um to make sure that we
can challenge hold to account the system
on those deliverables so those are just
some of the points the interviews
and are there any objections to being
part of the um the work
no hands so i'm taking that as a no
which is great and can we just make sure
helen that we have captured everybody
there's a couple of people in the noting
in the chat a couple of members who want
to be interviewed etc so and it's great
that people are on board for that
again and just a point really the couple
of the peers have got health experience
in their in their um portfolios as well
which i think is helpful it needs to
reflect both local government and health
colleagues as we move into the ics
changes which leads us very nicely onto
the last paper we've got on today the
nhs integrated care system updates
and i think tom is presenting this on my
right sir zara
yeah that's correct diane yeah thanks to
mom and over to you then
thanks very much and and good morning
everyone uh just for those who might not
know me my name's tom maloney um i'm
prominent program director across
health and care for this ccg and for the
council um i think sorry he's only on
her phone today so i'll take this but um
any questions i'm sure that i can answer
i'm sure sarah and george and others um
who are well involved in this work will
jump in as well and so people will have
received two slide deck which we'll run
through in a second but also a paper in
more detail which picks up um the uh
draft gm operating model which was
tabled in greater manchester before
christmas and i'll come on to a little
bit of detail of that in a short while
uh it's worth just noting chair that
behind the scenes alex has worked some
wonders because the place leader slides
that were involved uh included sorry
should i say in the original deck and
are now outdated and we've had the one
system board meeting and the ccg
governing body since um those papers
were circulated so we've managed to alex
has worked his magic and weaved in the
updated versions of those fights
following those two key meetings in the
last week and so i'll come on to those
and we can circulate those updated
slides after this session
are you okay sharing the slides alex
looks like it's warming up
oops
just useful to say well alex is just
trying to get some of the slides up
there is that a version of these slides
with more detail particularly on the
finances is going to be used in an
upcoming check and challenge session
with sarah price and sir richard lee's
which is part of um that conversation
around our locality operating model
and those conversations happening at the
one system board and ccg governing body
in recent days weeks um are contributing
to a revised version of this slide deck
um being used for for that meeting
um looks like alex having a little bit
of trouble getting the slides up um
but not to worry i'll just start um and
use my own local version here and so
there was some information around uh the
background but i think we're all
well-versed in the background of of the
white paper and the bill that is
currently passing through uh parliament
it is really important to note um that
at this moment in time um it has been
communicated that there is a delay to
the ics implementation obviously we were
aiming for april the 1st and that's what
we're preparing ourselves for with all
of the work programs we've mobilized
here in trafford and through greater
manchester but that has now been put
back to july and we see that as a
positive and that enables us i think
more flexibility than more opportunities
to have conversations with system
partners and to mature the arrangements
and ways of working and it gives it that
little bit of extra time and to do that
sense checking process and get
everything as refined as possible before
the implementation date of july the
first pending that parliamentary process
and
it also enables us to deal with what's
been raised on various occasions
throughout this meeting the response to
covid and the pressures that that is
currently seeing in the health and
social care system
it's also really important to note um
that the ccg still retains all its
duties until the end of june before we
go live with the new ics arrangements um
as set out in the nhs planning guidance
and there are going to be some changes
within the ccg to just know at a higher
level in terms of a shift towards a more
skeleton governing body and a slim down
set of arrangements over that extension
period which will still mean that
conduct of business can happen um in
line with strategy duty
and so just important to know that and
the relevant leadership roles
in terms of objectivity will all remain
in place to be sure smooth transition
and the new arrangements in july
alex he's still having a few issues
there trying to oh there we go looks
like oh it looked like it worked and
then it came back off
again i'll just i'll carry on um and and
just very very quickly touch on um a
paper which uh has been included with
the distribution of papers on the draft
gm operating model and that's really
really important in distinguishing and
what that means for our locality
operating but i'll move on to some of
the detail of that in a short while that
paper was presented to the joint
planning and delivery committee and just
before christmas and the recommendations
in there are
summarized in five integrated processes
that are essential for
the gm system as a whole to capitalize
on the components and therefore deliver
aims of the strategy over the next five
years um but importantly the next 12
months um in terms of that but that
clear direction of trouble over the next
five years um and those five just to
reiterate are creating that simple
narrative as to how the new system will
work across health and social care
finalizing the governance arrangements
of which um we are seeing some clarity
on those and the curation of the the
joint planning and delivery committee is
one element of that agreeing the
financial flows and responsibilities the
locality leadership arrangements which
we'll come onto in the presentation and
very importantly around the finances in
terms of the running cost allocate
allocations and that deployment of staff
within the national framework hr
framework
um
maybe you can just move on alex i think
i've covered those on the next slide as
well thank you
you just move on
thanks and this is a very high level um
pictorial about how we think our system
will work and interact both from uh
building up from people and communities
and neighborhoods um and building on
that principle of subsidiarity which is
very difficult to say but i managed to
do it then um all the way through to how
we will interact at that greater
manchester level through um the uh icb
board and icp board etc um this slide is
a little bit dated known probably a few
little bits of language need to change
given the recent um announcements around
governance but really importantly what
we're trying to emphasize here is that
we build from our communities upwards
and we will engage and do things at the
right spatial levels for the right
reasons which will then help us attain
the outcomes that are to the far
right-hand side of this diagram you can
move on alex
i'll touch on a few bits of this but i
think the assumptions are as a system at
this moment is that um and these aren't
probably rocket science assumptions but
actually
those structures uh that are being put
in place absolutely need to be within um
the running costs and the envelope that
is there and therefore need to be
affordable it is really important that
we capitalize on the opportunities of
the ics arrangements bringing the
legislation in terms of standardization
but absolutely here and be really really
clear on that that it is important that
our locality operating model and we
build from our communities upwards in
terms of our new uh and reformed and
transformed health and social care
services where it makes sense to do so
and that's the really key point to take
away
uh important to note the influence that
the icb executive directors will have in
terms of uh influencing what is done at
what level and we're yet to see who
those individuals are but the
recruitment process is ongoing um and i
have got some more detail that i could
share if people are interested in terms
of the dates of when those um roles are
being recruited too but uh
you must say that is a live exercise
that's happening throughout january and
february
um
and an acknowledgement that we
understand there will be that hub and
spoke model and i'll come on to a little
bit more of our assumptions at the
locality level of what that looks like
but there will be things that will be
done at greater manchester and things
that will be done at place
you can just move on
again
trying to simplify some of this we are
our approach here in trafford and what
we have um socialized through our
locality board we're trying to use that
language now in terms of instead of one
system board because we're a bit of an
outlier there it made sense at the time
to call it one system but i think we're
gradually shifting over to using the
terminology around locality board to
fall in line with other areas in greater
manchester but those conversations um
are really clear this is about minimal
changes um
now and the transformation and the
changes that will happen will be post uh
july whatever they may be the immediate
priority for us is that safe landing
into the new ics arrangements so that we
have a continuity of service as we're
stepping back up services and recovering
from corvid and making sure that that
supports a staff over what is a very
challenging time with anxiety and
uncertainty and that we do it in a very
um open and transparent way and our
position absolutely is that um
our teams will remain in the locality
when i sell our teams the six teams that
make up the ccg and again there's a
couple of slides which go into that
detail shot
just move on to the next slide thank you
um if you put this is an animated slide
and the text will be a little bit too
small to see but you can just whiz
through the animation alex and it will
pull in a very short descriptor of the
five keyboards that we have
now uh pause at that point thank you um
this is a very short description and a
lot of work and behind the scenes to be
really clear
each of these groups so you will see we
have on system board our locality board
currently chaired by a leader of the
council andrew wrestling mohammed the
chair of the ccg we have a traffic
provider collaborative board chaired by
diane um a co-chair should i say by
diane and jill heaton from mft
and then in the middle you have the
traffic clinical and practitioner center
which has been stood up as well as
obviously the provider club that have
bought in recent months in the initial
period of shadow there are terms of
working terms of reference for each of
those three boards and they are being
triangulated to ensure that there is
consistency and that there is um
no duplication in what those individual
boards are doing so being really clear
on roles and responsibilities and we've
had really honest conversations around
um we will need to mature these we will
need to change them over the coming
weeks and months
underneath that we have two engine rooms
in the steering groups that funnel the
work up towards provide a collaborative
with one system board and they are just
to really re-emphasize they are about
they are multi-stakeholder groups and
channeling the world if you can move on
uh very quickly we used to have six for
ics working groups i think that's been
reported here through the health and
wellbeing before we have seen that shift
now so the provider collaborative
working group and the clinical and
practitioner working group have actually
evolved into part of our shadow
governance and arrangements which has
left four remaining working groups which
are as i said before the engine rooms
behind systems governance performance
comms and engagement finance and that
whole transition of staff and
importantly the ways of working not just
the technical hiv or the ways of working
yourself that will be in the new world
you can quickly move on
um
this just very quickly list the six
teams within the the trafford ccg if you
move on to the next slide please alex it
starts to articulate
what the responsibilities are within
those teams and the full-time equivalent
so we understand how many people we are
talking about um and then obviously the
nuances there in terms of some of those
teams being shared with of trafford
council in terms of the pmo and strategy
where i say um and nhcc in terms of
performance and quality and so that's
what we're saying is those six
functions and teams within the ccg to be
really clear with colleagues as to what
what we have and therefore informing
a conversation around ways of working in
the new world
i won't go through every single one of
these six um but you will see that there
is um
there is a
a description to the right hand side
that tries to articulate what spatial
level we think these functions will act
and you will see there is
a number which are about having um
commissioning at the locality underneath
the place leader which i'll move on to
in a minute but aligned with our
providers so being really clear that
that's our position and understanding at
this moment in time and there are some
that are more um hub and spoke models so
if we understand there is going to be
benefits of doing things in greater
manchester but also under locality and
that leadership of the place leader so
that's those are our assumptions at this
moment in time are working assumptions
you can move on
right they should be the new slides
which you won't have seen in the
original pack um so
really importantly at one system board i
mean and subsequent conversations with
key colleagues from the board um i think
we've got real good clarity now on what
we think that place leader role um
should be um and the decision made in
the direction of travel is that they
will be directly accountable to the icb
executive other areas across greater
manchester are having different um
arrangements in terms of joint
arrangements with local authorities
and other
options as well but as a trafford
locality we decided that's the best fit
for us really important to note that we
to really anchor that place leader role
into trafford to achieve all of the
aspirations of our locality plan and all
of the health and wellbeing laws agenda
and tackling wider determinants etc then
what we need to do is anchor that into
um trafford council so there will be
that dotted line into the corporate
leadership team that is chaired by the
traffic council chief executive um and
the option is that the place leader will
sit on on clt so that we have that
influence across the wider systems of
making the connections into for example
this board in addition to other
keyboards such as traffic partnership
and i think that is absolutely critical
um otherwise we won't have that traction
and that influence to other key
strategies that we hold in the borough
you can just move on there's a list then
on the next um on the next slide around
the characteristics and duties and
obviously that is pending any kind of
publication um of a national role
profile and the ongoing consultation
within greater manchester within certain
senior leaders and so i won't go through
each of those i think we've been through
these in other forums and they are
really really core elements so there's a
few changes in there from previous
versions around being accountable simply
to the icb for all the aforementioned
reasons
but absolutely you know
the person that we want um in place
there has to be the advocate and
champion of all trafford's residence
voices to influence health and social
care and to do all of the things that
eleanor and helen very eloquently cut
across earlier on in their previous
reports you can move on i think we're
getting towards the end now um
i think that might be it actually there
may have been one other slide and i
think it was simply just to sort of
recap on some of the really key uh
elements and next steps and that was
so
the chief executive and the executive
director pulse at greater manchester
level
around and the connections between the
gym operating model and our law and the
i think
tom may have frozen
i can totally just confirm they can hear
me
yeah you know yeah thank you thank you
and i wonder if you could just take the
slides down alex i think we more or less
finish
sarah sorry i know you're on on the
phone but i wonder whether you wanted to
just um pick up any summary points there
yeah thanks diane i hope everyone can
hear me so just really in summary
the icb and what it's doing
basically just needs to deliver our
locality plan and so it's new structures
it's new reorganization nationally but
we just really need to be focused on
what that means for trafford so for me
it's about delivering the locality plan
which we all signed up for 2018 it's
been refreshed it's about traffic people
traffic as a place and our population
everything we've been discussing this
morning so that has to be our driver the
locality operating model has brought all
of our partners together we continue to
do that and it needs to be based around
our communities and neighborhoods so we
build from the bottom up in terms of
co-production which is everything that
we've always talked about the local icb
shadow architecture which
one put up and that's been built on what
we've been doing so locality board is
built on the joint commissioning board
which we've had since 2018 we've added
partners to it so it's strengthened it
for the next steps and the provider
collaborative board is built on the
local care alliance which again we've
had for numerous years and we've built
on it especially through the pandemic
with care providers coming on board
primary care networks coming on board
etcetera so i think we're in a strong
position on what we are building on as
we go forward um as tom said the place
leader role that's in discussion across
the whole of gm for us it's a role which
obviously is accountable to the icb but
it's anchored in trafford and the
anchoring being about how it works
across those wider health and wellbeing
agendas um such as regeneration sitting
with council colleagues etc and we'll do
that um it must be noticed that's
subject to an hr process
because there are 52 senior leaders in
gm which who are at risk of their roles
and because of the disestablishment of
12 sender organizations into the icb
so that will be part of a process as we
go forward to name that place leader
but until that happens
myself and gareth as joint accountable
officers as the ccg will take that role
but only until that process um is
completed and what that means
any ways of working that we have um into
traffic will be with agreement with all
of our partners around the locality
board
and particularly those big providers
that we have um within traffic who cover
a lot of our services um mft gmh etc so
it will be done in partnership with
people this is not a sort of top down at
all approach to what will happen
um and just in terms of the delay so
people know every um person below board
level in the cccg is subject to a lift
and shift so their roles will basically
be shifted into the icb contractually
without any change
and that will happen on the first of
july so those are those teams that you
saw when tom put up but obviously as we
move into the icb there will be
transformation at spatial level be that
gm or trafford but we're really clear
working with partners about the people
that we need to continue to deliver the
locality plan um within trafford the ccg
will be just established at the end of
june and that will mean that it's bored
um and all its stature responsibilities
will go into the icb and its board
members will cease to have a role at
that point um and that includes the
three executive board members those
officers um
um which is the accountable officer and
the medical director and also the chair
and the way members at that point um so
that will be a major change at the end
of june
sorry diane if that was repeating lots
of things but i hope in summary just say
those are the main points thank you
thanks sarah and thanks for joining by
phone on your day off it's really
helpful and i do i do stress that the
locality plan embeds the health and
well-being priorities so
our role as health and well-being board
is to make sure that during what is a
massive system change we don't lose
sight of what is really important to
track of people about improving the
population for the health of our
population
uh maureen do you want to come in
thanks chair i just wanted to uh to add
and we've had a similar presentation
this week a safeguarding partnership the
the expectation in relation to statutory
safeguarding partners which exist both
under the care act for adults and under
working together to safeguard children
there is an expectation that those
arrangements will continue
irrespective of the architecture at
local level
there have been ministerial letters to
safeguarding partnerships about that and
we are very much engaged in the
discussion around how we ensure
those statutory responsibilities around
safeguarding continue and how we can in
fact strengthen them through ics and the
icb so
again re really useful to
see that conversation playing out in the
presentation today but i wanted to offer
that reassurance around the sanctuary if
you will of safeguarding
no that's really helpful maureen and we
did follow up on the discussion with
jackie coulson and myself angel about
making sure that the commitment
safeguarding boards goes into
the locality and
held funds as well to make sure that
that is
kept local
so thank you thank you for that i can't
see any other hands up and i'm conscious
we have three minutes let's try to
summarize and then and suggest some
areas that we would want to look at next
time
so today we've had a really i think
quite a good um journey through the
agenda and re-looking through the public
health report at the priorities and for
health and well-being that will uh
continue to drive the improvements
and level up some of the inequality
issues that have been
highlighted in the report
those are being uh taken forward now
into the ambitions for the board and the
implementation there'll be a cross-check
with our
current work programmes to see if there
are any gaps where work is not
in play
and any of those gaps will then be
addressed and look at who is the most
appropriate provider or deliverer of
those uh priorities
and we've also um had a look and at the
at
the overview uh report of child deaths
and the health uh health visitor and
school nursing review which is all uh
feed into those priorities and are part
of that delivery and accepted the
recommendations from both of those
reports
and the work on refreshing the um
the health and wellbeing um
overview and ways of working for the
future will help us to really think
about how we align
our work here against the changes in the
integrated care system
and and
the changing delivery time of that has
been noted and gives us a little bit
more time to make sure that we are
aligned in able to
one contribute influence and and ensure
outcomes are tracked and monitored
against the health of
the public health priorities as we go
forward and we thank tom and uh for the
ics update it's a very difficult time
for all of our colleagues and that's
also noted and and being kept well
informed is really important during such
big such a big change
and it is our role as a health and
wellbeing partner is to make sure that
we support all of our teams and services
through that change to make sure that at
the heart of what we're trying to do is
the improvements that are set out in the
in the health and well-being priorities
and plans
so thank you very much for um being here
today for the
contributions that people have made and
the support to some of quite some of the
recommendations which are challenging
and will require us to create the
influencing role that we need to have as
a health and well-being board thank you
for contributing to the local government
association review because that is
really important and making sure we've
got the right people here and we're
covering all of the partners and that we
have got that wider influence and uh
ability to drive some of those changes
forward so can i suggest next time we
would want to have a look at the
measures and that we want to set against
each of those ambitions and and the
dials that we need to start to see
shifting shifting
and
and that would be really helpful to come
in next time and i do think there's some
questions around things like domestic
violence
substance misuse and mental health and
maternity services raised today that
would ask public health to consider what
what the health and well-being board may
want to
look at in in the future and to help
without those ambition setting sessions
so i've got eleanor and then jill
my one was just a really quick process
point which is i think we're going to
try and move the meetings to a tuesday
so the dates that are currently in
people's calendars will probably change
the tuesday before but alex will send
that round but it was just to alert
people
to that eleanor and i think that is
important we've got a couple of key
people who are in surgery on
friday and that's a problem isn't that
so thank you jill
just in terms of the real practical in
terms of the date checking start well
usually on a tuesday or thursday for
that very reason so we'll just need to
do that sense check and just when you
mentioned mental health we did have a an
email exchange about whether we needed
to bring anything to health and
well-being
about children's mental health and some
of the pressures in the system and
obviously eleanor and helen have
mentioned children's mental health in
the report so i think we would welcome
the opportunity of
um
sharing what some of those risks are
currently in the system the ways that
they're that we're trying to address
them and just some of that forward
planning thank you
thanks jill and i would stress that that
needs to be on an all-age basis and and
i think in hell in this report it did
pull through waiting times were
increasing so i do think it is probably
an area the board would want to look at
any other
comments before i move on just the last
item to cover is any urgent business
that we need to address today
can't see any hands on either count and
so a massive thank you for everyone's
contribution today and your time as well
i think it's been a productive session
thank you for to helen and ellen for
arranging the agenda and helping us and
tom for presenting as well and for um to
make sure that we cover everything that
we needed to get through meaty agenda
but really helpful thank you everybody